Between Ghostbusters, Spaceballs, and Honey,
I Shrunk the Kids, Rick Moranis earned his
status as one of the great comedy icons of
the ‘80s. Sadly, the actor has since stepped
away from the camera, leaving us to wonder
exactly what happened. Here's what we know
about Rick Moranis leaving Hollywood, in his
own words.
(Rick Moranis gibberish)
Family Man
Moranis stopped appearing in live-action movies
after his wife, Ann, died of breast cancer
in 1997. Immediately after, he shifted his
focus to raising their two children. In the
rare interviews he's given over the years
since her passing, Moranis has remained nonchalant
about his decision to become a stay-at-home-dad.
In 2015, he told The Hollywood Reporter:
"I took a break, which turned into a longer
break.”
Fiercely protective of his children, he won't
even reveal their names to the press.
It’s Not Unusual
These days, giving up a multi-million-dollar
movie career at its peak might seem like a
crazy idea. But when he made his decision
to leave Hollywood, Moranis didn't think he
was doing anything out of the norm. He told
the podcast Bullseye with Jesse Thorn:
"Stuff happens to people every day, and they
make adjustments in their lives, for all kinds
of reasons. There was nothing unusual about
what happened or what I did."
In fact, Moranis believes people only paid
attention at the time because he was walking
away from money and fame.
"Because I came from celebrity and fame and
what was a peak of a career, that was intriguing
to people. And to me it wasn't that, it wasn't
anything to do with that. It was just work,
and it was time to make an adjustment."
Missing the Action
Moranis described "a lot of sameness" when
it came to raising kids. So, he admitted to
Bullseye that there were certain parts about
acting that he did actually miss:
"I missed the people, and I missed the very
refreshing nature of doing something radically
different every day."
Still, he didn't look back with any regrets.
He said later to The Hollywood Reporter:
"I found lots of joy and lots of rewards in
other places. I was working with really interesting
people, wonderful people. I went from that
to being at home with a couple of little kids,
which is a very different lifestyle. But it
was important to me. I have absolutely no
regrets whatsoever. My life is wonderful."
Don’t Call It A Comeback
Contrary to many reports, Moranis maintains
that he never actually retired from show business.
Case in point: he's done a ton of voice work
over the years, including radio commercials
and Disney's Brother Bear film series.
He’s also done some op-ed contributing for
The New York Times. So if you want to know
how many sinks he has, you’re in luck. Spoiler
alert: it’s five.
Moranis has also released two albums over
ten years. The first, The Agoraphobic Cowboy,
earned him a Grammy nomination for Best Comedy
Album. The second, My Mother's Brisket & Other
Love Songs, hit stores in 2013. In other words,
he's totally still around. You just have to
listen more carefully.
"Howdy I'm rick how are ya man?"
"Hello!"
"It's always swell to run across another oatmeal
fan."
All In Good Time
Naturally, when a star as big as Moranis takes
a break from making movies, the question's
going to come up. When will he be back? For
years, Moranis dodged that question, often
implying that acting just wasn't on his radar.
In 2006, he told USA Today:
"I'm a single parent, and I just found that
it was too difficult to manage raising my
kids and doing the traveling involved in making
movies. I found that I really didn't miss
it. In the last few years I've been offered
a number of parts in movies, and I've just
turned them down. I don't know whether I'll
go back to it or not."
However, in 2015, Moranis admitted to The
Hollywood Reporter that he's potentially interested
in pursuing live-action roles in the future.
It's just going to have to be the right one,
saying:
"I still get the occasional query about a
film or television role and as soon as one
comes along that piques my interest, I'll
probably do it. I'm happy with the things
I said yes to, and I'm very happy with the
many things I've said no to. Yes, I am picky,
and I'll continue to be picky. Picky has worked
for me."
Who You Gonna Call?
Paul Feig's much-anticipated Ghostbusters
reboot is among the many scripts that have
come to Moranis over the years. Despite the
cameos from Bill Murray, Dan Aykroyd, and
Sigourney Weaver, Moranis turned the project
down. The reason? It didn’t appeal to him.
He told The Hollywood Reporter:
"I wish them well. I hope it's terrific. But
it just makes no sense to me. Why would I
do just one day of shooting on something I
did 30 years ago?"
Fair enough, but we're still pretty bummed
he said no.
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the one
you just saw. And leave us a comment to let
us know your favorite Rick Moranis role...